what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we'll be looking at one
of the manliest men in anime and what he
can teach us about how to be a man
of course I'm referring to SK Nord
Alliance and pride himself keep in mind
there's a lot of different versions of
masculinity out there but with this
series I want to look at different epic
role models from anime and highlight
their best attributes which we can learn
from and use in order to improve our own
lives if you liked the idea for this new
series definitely smash that like button
to let me know if you have it be sure to
subscribe and this is absolutely crucial
make sure to hit that notification bell
so you actually get notified when new
videos drop keep in mind there will be
manga spoilers in this video now without
further ado let's jump into it ESCA noir
has had quite the astonishing impact on
anime fans in the history of anime
characters very few characters have
managed to garner as much hype as Eskin
or people love him and the question is
how can you learn from his example so
that you two can have a similar kind of
impact on the people around you perhaps
you can't become a jack ten-foot-tall
golden giant shooting suns out of your
hands during high noon but that's not
really what makes Eskin or such a good
male role model
it says mindset and behavior both of
which you can start implementing in your
own life starting today first of all
there is day x ESCA NORs insane level of
confidence
ESCA noir is called the center pride for
a reason he takes a lot of pride in
himself and some people may call him
straight-up arrogant we've seen this
kind of behavior in many famous and
successful people like boxer Muhammad
Ali who once said I'm not the greatest
I'm the double greatest not only do I
knock him out I picked around
similarly Kanye West is known for his
cocky quotes like when he said I just
told you who I thought I was a god I
just told you that's who I think I am
and quote s Kannur has said comparable
things he said that King's compared to
him are as common as grains of sand he
has said that he stands at the pinnacle
of all races what's important about this
as Oscar is not just covering up his
insecurities by pretending to be
confident he backs up his big talk the
energy radiating from
ESCA Knorr body alone literally turns
the vampire king is rough into grades of
sand s can or says he stands at the
pinnacle of all races then he goes on to
easily defeat some of the strongest
members of some of the strongest clans
like GLE and mulaskey la esta rosa and
eventually assault mode Mellie Otis
obviously I'm not suggesting you go
around telling people you're a god and
that you're better than everyone else
around you that probably wouldn't make
you very popular with people but s
Kannur teaches us that we should be
confident and be able to back up our
talk you don't have to be the best
fighter but find something you are
really passionate about whether that's
writing YouTube mathematics gaming or
whatever else just find something you
love and put work into it every day
until you get to a point like Eskin or
where you have become confident in that
area even Eskin or doesn't excel in all
areas like in love for instance but he
does excel at fighting and people
respect him for that once you start to
excel in one area especially in an area
that's important to you then you will
naturally begin to be more confident and
almost everyone is attracted to
confidence as long as it's not
delusional confidence covering up
insecurity so put in the work grow your
confidence and reap the rewards another
aspect of Norse character is bravery we
know that Eska nor is brave because he
fights even when it seems futile and
when he's clearly outmatched for
instance when a baby in Deraa got away
from bonds attack it went on to attack
yell thunder and his friends despite the
fact that s Kannur without sunshine is
the weakest of the holy Knights with
only a power level of 15 that's half the
power level of hawk people he still ends
up stepping in to protect guilt thunder
against the powerful enduro
he is ready to sacrifice his life for
his friends and for the future
generation he is ready to face death
with a smile before mile comes in to
save him this moment is vital because it
shows that s Kannur wasn't simply
fighting all those times because he
always knew he would win even when
fighting means he'll all but certainly
lose his life he is willing to do it he
is willing to die for his principles and
ideals for a cause greater than himself
it's not that s Kannur isn't scared
we know that night time s Kannur
one of the most scared characters in the
seven deadly sins but he is able to do
the right thing in the face of all that
fear and that is exactly what makes him
brave it is only when we are scared that
we can be brave so remember do the right
thing and take action even in the face
of fear as you do that your comfort zone
will expand and you'll be able to do
greater and greater things and a key to
being brave is not being selfish like
Eskin or if you have ideals and a cause
greater than yourself to think about
like your family friends community or
even the world then it becomes much
easier to act with courage as many anime
have taught us having someone to protect
makes you stronger so be less selfish do
what scares you and be ready to suffer
perhaps even die for your dreams h0 or
des the creator of one piece once said
that people who work on his manga have
to be willing to die for one piece that
is exactly the kind of attitude and
level of dedication you want to bring
into your own life
next up s kannur the lie instead of
pride doesn't concern himself with the
opinions of sheep ESCA nor doesn't go
around seeking approval with everyone he
meets
ghal and animal ask allah say that Eskin
or doesn't stand a chance against that
does this bother Eskin or not at all he
is confident in his own abilities and he
proves them wrong by beating them he
does the same when he fights esta rosa
both Esther OSA and soldiers think the
fight is over
when Esther OSA counters esken oars
physical attack and seemingly swallows
up his son with darkness yet s Kannur
doesn't give up he's quick enough to
land a physical attack on a serosa
before he can counter it and he's strong
enough to completely overpower Esther
Rosa's darkness as s kannur mentions no
one else gets to decide whether he's
done for the one who gets to decide such
things is esken or himself
similarly in life you will have a lot of
people telling you what you can and
can't do what your limitations are when
my brother and I started working on
YouTube people told us that we were
wasting our time they told us that we
were never going to be able to make a
living off of YouTube but we didn't let
the opinions of those people become our
reality we didn't let them impose their
own limitations on to us we stuck to it
and as of now we've already been living
of YouTube for two years and Counting
you'll have many such experiences in
life you'll have a dream or a goal and
people will tell you that you can't
accomplish it but at the end of the day
a man decides such things for himself as
Henry Ford once said whether you think
you can do a thing or think you can't do
a thing you're right then there's the
fact that s Kannur is extremely positive
and doesn't complain this is absolutely
huge s Kunwar has the power to
practically reframe everything that
happens into a positive at one point
during the fight with Testarossa s
serosa uses full counter and for the
first time s Canora looks surprised and
how much damage was dealt to him
Esther OSA goes on to explain that any
physical attack made against him he can
return many times over keep in mind at
this point it appears that a serosa has
turned the tide of the battle he's
figured out a way to significantly
damage Eskin or a lesser man might have
been worried but not s Kannur s Kannur
turns the damage into a freaking
complement he cheerily says I see no
wonder that hurt so badly just as I'd
expect from myself
he doesn't even lose his cool for a
moment and goes on to find a way to
defeat Testarossa something similar
happens when Mellie Otis loses his
memories that enters assault mode
everyone is terrified by the powerful
out-of-control demon Prince when she
sees him Alaska says it's all over this
is the end for all of you seven deadly
sins and me as well
that is the Mele Otis even we used to
fear back when he had command of the Ten
Commandments
his assault mode upon hearing this s
Canora calmly lets Merlin know to set up
the perfect cube around him and melly
Otis not only does s Kannur step up to
the seemingly impossible task of beating
a god of demons he is even in an
extremely good mood because this is the
perfect chance for him to prove just how
much stronger he is than Melly Otis a
huge life-threatening obstacle presents
itself and s Kannur reframes it as a
great opportunity to test himself we'll
also have similar charges in our lives
although they usually won't be
life-threatening like Eskin ORS next
time you come up against an obstacle
think of s Kannur and reframe it as an
opportunity to test yourself gain
experience and become strong
next time you feel like complaining
think about how s Kannur took 1000
divine slashes from full power meli otis
and claimed it was but an itch when he
must have felt excruciating pain
think about how even after the battle s
Kannur remain cheery and claimed he
would rough up Melly Otis as many times
as it takes even though he was just one
light punch away from passing out
practice reframing every event into a
positive one and stop complaining you
will instantly be on a path to a life
filled with more happiness success and
positive relationships another big thing
that stood out to me about s Kannur is
how much he cares about his friends it
isn't easy to make a character as
powerful and arrogant as Eskin or so
unanimously likeable but one of the ways
nock of a Suzuki pulls it off is by
making him less self-centered and more
focused on his friends after Gotthard
tried to make Eskin or suffer by feeding
his mind images of a Merlin who would
never love him ESCA nor transforms it
says daytime form apparently a mental
image of Merlin the woman he loves can
have a similar impact on him as the son
however s can or does not act in the way
you'd expect he doesn't try to get even
with Goethe er for his horrible behavior
even as go Thurs firing an attack at
esken or esken or fires an attack at
drawl and gloxinia for toying with
goethe er who is s canora's precious
friend similarly during the fight
against the original demon s Kannur says
that whether he has to give up his power
of the sun or his very life he doesn't
mind
as long as it would mean that he could
save merlin and the captain s can or
would literally give anything to protect
his friends since he appreciates them
and what they did for him so much when
everyone else viewed him as a monster
they accepted him and praised him s
Kannur is extremely grateful for getting
to spend time with such amazing people
and he is willing to die to pay them
back for their kindness as I said before
asking or couldn't care less about those
people who hurt him or his friends he
doesn't give an F about what those
people think however when it comes to
people who have supported him and cared
for him he would do anything to help
them if you act like Eskin or if you're
grateful for the people who have
treated you kindly and you treat them
even kinder in return you will develop
strong friendships that will make your
life exponentially better we human
beings are social creatures we need
friendship to survive all great things
were done by a team of like-minded
people like the seven deadly sins this
YouTube channel is the same we have a
team of people working to put out as
many videos as we do and you are you
watching this video are part of that
team as well if you're lucky enough to
find pause their friends who support you
rather than put you down appreciate them
treat them well and you will be rewarded
many times over learn from Eskin or
never take good friends for granted now
make sure to stay tuned until the end of
the video if you want to see a bonus
point about what s Canora can teach us
about manliness but first I want to
thank you for watching this video if you
did enjoy this type of video definitely
smash that like button to let me know
and leave the names of some of your
favorite manly anime characters in the
comments if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is absolutely crucial
make sure to hit that notification bell
so you actually get notified when future
videos come out if you want to channel
Eskin ors manliness you can check out
our shirts like Eskin or praise the sun
and Eskin or all hail the one you can
purchase these and many more right now
at anime uproar calm link in the
description make sure to follow my
personal Instagram at project uproar for
more self development related content
like this which focuses on how you can
get closer and closer to becoming the
best version of yourself every day a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ljus and angel Cruz
and are the one to your patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans baby ray a 17mm
DP Steven and Greta a lowland autumn
Maddie Mac 239 makoto-kun
and Kela and the patrons who transcend
greatness itself Regan Harrison and Lord
Noxon or the chosen few who have been
acknowledged by Lord we go hymns
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
slash anime uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these epic people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon calm
length in the description if you're
interested and now for the bonus point
embrace what you love no matter what
others may think about it you may not
expect it at first but Eskin or loves
poetry this applies to his daytime form
as well before Merlin uses the spell
blackout arrow on Eskin or and the bonus
vampires of Edinburgh manga he is about
to tell her that he made a poem for her
his daily routine usually consists of
napping and writing poetry some people
may think that's lame but Eskin or
doesn't care he writes poetry because it
is a passion of his similarly some
people think that anime is lame or for
kids and I don't care because I love it
being a man means being unapologetic
about what you love even if people might
not think it's cool and if on the off
chance someone would actually insult you
or ignore you because of something you
love then good riddance to those people
not everyone's going to like you and
you're not going to like everyone live
by the words of dr. Seuss be who you are
and say what you feel because those who
mind don't matter and those who matter
don't mind that's all for this one until
next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]